[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Many apps use audio
to create amazing experiences.
Whether it's DJing,
karaoke, or musical games,
audio is a powerful tool for
expression, entertainment,
and creativity.
Today, I'm going to show you how
Oboe, a new C++ audio library,
makes it easy to
build interesting,
interactive audio
experiences on Android.
But first, what do we
mean by interactive audio?
Consider this keyboard.
I press a key, the keyboard
makes a sound immediately.
This makes the keyboard
feel incredibly responsive,
because I get instant
audible feedback.
It's part of what makes
playing an instrument
such a joyous experience.
But imagine if,
after hitting a key,
I had to wait to hear the sound.
This delay, or
latency, would make
the keyboard difficult
and frustrating to play.
The same applies
in apps and games,
whether it's rhythm games and
karaoke, DJing and scratching
apps, virtual reality,
synthesizers, drum machines,
and other virtual instruments.
All these apps share the
same common requirement,
they need low-latency audio
to provide a great user
experience.
And that's exactly
what Oboe does.
It's a C++ library which makes
it easy to obtain the lowest
possible audio latency on
any given Android device.
It works with API
16 and above, which
means it's compatible with
over 99% of Android devices.
Under the hood, it uses
AAudio on API 27 and above,
falling back to OpenSL
ES on all the API levels.
This way, Oboe provides a
single, easy-to-use API,
which takes advantage
of the new features
and better
performance in AAudio,
while still providing backward
compatibility with all
the devices.
To get started with
Oboe, all you need to do
is clone the
repository from GitHub.
This will copy the library
to your local machine.
Oboe is designed to be built
as a CMake sub-project.
To build it, you need to
update your project CMake
configuration.
If you don't have an
existing CMake configuration,
you'll need to add C++ support
to your app by following
the link below.
First, tell your project
where the Oboe source code is.
That's the path to which
you've cloned the repository.
Next, add this path
as a subdirectory,
and add the public headers.
Finally, add Oboe as
a dependent library.
To have Android Studio index
the library, go to Build,
Refresh Link to C++ Project.
Now that's done, you can use
Oboe objects in your code
by including the Oboe header.
All objects are in
the Oboe namespace,
so they won't clash with
any other namespaces
you might be using.
Now you are ready to
start using the Oboe API.
Check out the Getting Started
guide, the code samples,
and the code lab, all
available on the GitHub
site linked below.
If you have any
problems or questions,
please post them in the Issues
section on our GitHub site,
and we'll do our very
best to help you out.
You can learn more
about Oboe, including
how to create
low-latency audio streams
and a high-priority
audio callback
in the next video in the
series, Making Sounds With Oboe.
That's all for now.
So good luck, and
go make some noise.
[MUSIC PLAYING]